okay so what is this really about is
this really about this comedian who has
long-form conversations with mma
fighters and comedians and politicians
a guy who is mostly a lefty who was a
bernie supporter i mean the funny part
of this is the people who love to cancel
people should still love rogan because
even though rogan has sat down with all
of these amazing thinkers on the right
and people who talk about freedom all
the time and has interviewed uh you know
say jordan peterson probably eight eight
or nine times it's like rogan still came
to the conclusion that he should vote
for bernie sanders and support bernie
sanders it's like that's a whole other
issue entirely but this is a guy who
left california because of taxes right
he gets 100 million bucks then leaves
california because of high taxes brought
to you by bernie types brought to you by
progressives to move to texas where
there is no state income tax so it's not
even like he has like a completely
holistic view of the world that fully
makes sense in line with whatever
they're trying to destroy it's just
also silly but perhaps it's not
about covid misinformation specifically
and perhaps it's not about
uh
talking about the n word in the past
even though you didn't mean to be racist
perhaps what this is about is that
it's an upending of the world order the
media landscape has changed so
drastically and this is the machine's
way of showing who's still boss
so here are two propagandists by the
name of brian stelter and jim acosta
these are democrats who are on a network
known as cnn which was a place for news
at one time although actually in
retrospect we didn't have the internet
so who knows how much they've been lying
about the entire time but these are
democrats who pretend to be journalists
um who now are quite happy actually that
spotify
is punishing joe rogan take a look joe
rogan is now apologizing after videos
resurfaced of him using the n-word
multiple times on his podcast patriot
takes which put the video together as an
organization that aims to expose
extremism on the far right the video is
an edited compilation of different
podcast episodes brian uh what is joe
rogan now saying
he is now apologizing and we're going to
find out if that's enough for spotify
the company that has an exclusive
distribution deal with him jim this is
all coming to light because of the
recent controversy about anti-vaccine
rhetoric on rogan's podcast some artists
uh decided to quit the service one of
them india ahri pointed out this video
this compilation video and pointed out
that the language rogan has used around
race in the past is just as or maybe
even more problematic than his rhetoric
about vaccines that would be enough to
put anybody out of a job i mean to me i
i it seems untenable to have that kind
of video surface that kind of
compilation surface and keep one's job
joe rogan can continue to host his
podcast if people want to listen to it
they can but it doesn't have to be on
spotify there are many examples
including hollywood and entertainment
where people have uh have lost their
roles for less than this and that may be
why spotify is being so quiet at the
same time i want to recognize there are
reasons why rogan has lots of fans
millions of fans people want to hear his
candid conversations but there's a
difference between that between candid
in-depth conversations and the kind of
vile that's in this compilation
kyle there is bile and it's being spewed
by you mr potato head the way they are
drooling the way they are drooling at
someone should how could he keep a job
what was the line that would be enough
for anyone to lose their job that's
basically what acosta said notice that
they never said
that he didn't use the n-word to be
racist he didn't use it in a pejorative
manner that he used it when he was
either repeating what other people said
or when he was mocking people or
anything else they never say that but
they do say far right there's a website
these people create compilation videos
to guard against the far right and then
they use the name joe rogan do you see
guys how this whole thing comes together
and why are they really upset one more
time guys why are they really upset do
you think that jim acosta democratic
activist jim acosta and democratic
activist potato head do you think that
they are actually offended by joe rogan
repeating a word uh in a non-offensive
way
or is it because more people are paying
attention to joe rogan that nobody
nobody would pay a dime for jim acosta
or brian stelter if they did not have
cnn next to their name and cnn which is
crumbling and jeff zucker just had to
step down and uh two been masturbated on
a zoom call and don lemon uh did some
weird [ __ ] and they had to get rid of
cuomo and the whole thing the place is
going down right the place is going down
okay fine
um but when it goes down jim acosta is
not going to be able to go independent
and create a podcast that anyone will
pay for
right
brian stelter nobody cares about brian
stelter these are people who are
corporate suck-ups
they are i don't know how to describe
them in any other way because they lie
about absolutely everything and they're
now lying about their opponent because
they want to take out their opponent